ces chèvres ce sont celles de jean
françois
il ya un an leur maître s'est enlevé la
vie
un coup très dur pour sa conjointe et
leurs deux enfants comment j'ai pu le
perdre comme ça mais pas me rendre
compte qu'ils étaient autant de 13
depuis un an caroline tardy est en mode
survie
elle s'occupe seule de leurs deux
enfants et d'entreprises
la fromagerie du ruban bleu on vient
tellement des esclaves de l'agriculture
un peu que on oublie de prendre soin et
je n'oublie comprendre qu'il était des
fois exécuté fatigué mais je me donnais
mon anniversaire notre métier on n'a pas
le choix que jean-françois faut
continuer pendant quinze ans ils ont
travaillé sans relâche 7 jours sur 7
la norme en agriculture comment on peut
choisir une vie qui semble si c'est un
retour aux valeurs puis autant
travailler puissent perdre pied est
déconnecté de plaisir la ville certaines
journées ben oui je vais parcourir deux
salles jusqu'à trois ou quatre cents
kilomètres dans une journée
cette travailleuse sociale est débordé
son organisme au coeur des familles
agricoles offrent du soutien à domicile
aux agriculteurs elle est seule pour
répondre à tous les appels à l'aide
en montérégie l'objectif principal de
l'organisme c'est de répondre aux
besoins dans les deux premières semaines
suivant la demande days présent place
est pas toujours possible au coeur des
familles agricoles c'est une maison de
répit à saint-hyacinthe
beaucoup d'agriculteurs ont besoin de
repos et de réfléchir à leur avenir
si on regarde des études qui ont été
faites en 2006 au québec les études qui
ont été faites au canada dans les deux
trois dernières années
on arrive à des à des constances ou est
ce que les agriculteurs ont des taux de
13 du sco logique qui sont autour de 50%
alors que dans la population c'est
autour de 20
22 23 pour ça oui l endettement oui les
problèmes de transport nous sommes
exécutés que tout le monde peuvent vivre
mais leurs contextes dans lesquels
vivent vos complexifier le fond là leur
situation
surtout qu'en agriculture la vie
familiale et le travail ne font qu'un
c'est certain car on dit chez nous on
mange le soir puis on voit notre travail
ça s'arrête et fait ça c'est vrai
j'oubliais sauce ici donc c'est sûr que
ça rumine tout le temps puisque
jean-françois c'est sûr qu'il y avait
cette partie l'ennui s'était jamais
assise à ça s'ajoute le stress financier
à tous les maux chaque sens de leur
rentrée vont le surveiller parce qu'il
fallait qu'ils ont fait un conte à côté
donc on n'a jamais été capable qu'un
vent de dire h dégage un coussin québec
dit vouloir venir en aide aux
agriculteurs en détresse
le ministère de la santé a récemment
accordé un montant de 300 mille dollars
à l'organisme au coeur des familles
agricoles
mais caroline tardif crois qu'il faut en
faire plus il est des cours à l'église
de préparation au mariage des cours de
préparation à vivre en couple sur une
entreprise aussi à voir les détresses de
l'autre aujourd'hui caroline tardif
tente de prendre du temps pour elle elle
doit garder le fort malgré la souffrance
et l'incompréhension ici marie-eve
cousineau radio canada merci